hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor i've done over 300
property deals
and made millions of pounds investing in
property but this is not about me right
now
this is about you so i'm going to be
answering all of
your property investment questions
helping you in your journey so
if you've got a question about property
or if you haven't succeeded in property
yet
the reason i believe you haven't
succeeded is because you're stuck
somewhere
so how are you stuck what do you need to
know
in order to help you succeed in property
comment that below
and then i'm going to answer that my
very best and help you next week
this week right now i'm going to be
looking at last week's questions
if you enjoy my videos please do me a
massive favor and smash the like button
and also subscribe so you don't miss a
future video because i've got some
really good
um videos coming up where i'm going to
be answering some very interesting
questions
let's have a look what we had last week
so ems fmm said hi samuel my fiance and
i
just made 30 000 pounds on our home our
first home
unintentionally from covet we are now
moving into a caravan and using that
money to get our first buy to let
okay are we being stupid
what would you do in our situation
so i would not in your situation move
into a caravan but that's only because
it's getting
cold right now and i wouldn't want to
move into a caravan
uh however are you being stupid not
necessarily
i mean some people would say you're
being really smart they'd say you're
living below your means
you're taking your equity you're
investing it and and you're getting a
return on that passive income from that
so fair play
um i would say i probably wouldn't want
to move into a caravan
because okay i used to teach a little
bit differently back in the day if you
spoke to me seven eight nine ten years
ago
i was all for live below your means and
save every penny
now i believe in the power of
environment and if your environment
is not good if you're in a little
caravan
and you're trying to become successful i
mean i think you're really going to
struggle i don't really
buy into that anymore however if you
want to live in a caravan
live in a caravan i'm sure it's really
cheap also
here's the thing right all depends on
why you're doing it if you're trying to
delay gratification and be rich one day
i don't think it's the fastest way to
get there taking 30 000 pounds and
buying a buy to let
i'd rather put that into a business a
property business
like deal packaging or rent to rent
because if you buy a buy to let property
it's going to give you what a couple
hundred pounds a month profit
great and then what you're going to save
up another 30 000 pounds
by living in a caravan for for the next
five or ten years and then buy another
buy to net profit it's going to give you
a couple hundred pounds a month
what we do that's good that means for
the next 30 40 years before you're
financially free you're going to be in a
caravan
i just wouldn't do that i would be
wanting to make more money
put that 30 grand into a property
business
and get some serious fast pound coming
in so
are you being stupid probably not would
i do it
probably not hope that helps all right
uh uh
are on who i attended your crash course
last november at hilton hotel my
question is are lease options
corporate let's no lease options and
corporates are two very separate things
a lease option is when you buy a
property now and you pay for it later
it's a way of buying a purchasing a
property
and corporate let's is when a company
rents a property so they're two very
separate things
sounds like you're a bit stuck to me how
can i help you comment below what's
going on
razvan gabriel as a first-time buyer
would you buy a house
now with 15 deposit or wait a few months
until it gets back to five percent
so presumably you're talking as a
first-time buyer and you're talking
about a residential home to live in
because
i i assume you're talking about boris
johnson's announcement where he said
that he's going to be making it possible
to buy a property
to live in if you're a first-time buyer
with five percent i would wait
i would wait and see what that's about
because they are gonna do that
and i think it sounds like it could be
quite exciting and i definitely wouldn't
be rushing to buy a property to live in
anyway so i would just hold out i
wouldn't be buying a house right now
and putting down 15 percent to live in i
wouldn't do that i would wait
see what the announcement is but i'm not
even excited about any of that anyway
because this is all about
buying a property to live in which
doesn't excite me in the slightest the
house that i live in i don't even own
i'm all about building wealth and
lifestyle so it doesn't really excite me
but i would definitely hold off and see
what the announcement is if you're
wanting to buy a house delivered
all right bijan my question is would it
be
best to buy properties to rent as
individuals
or through a limited company if you buy
properties as individuals how do you get
the best tax relief
is it more difficult to get mortgage
under business
with higher interest rates you say you
have most of your rental houses
as an individual how do you make it work
okay so bjn great questions so firstly
the reason
that i have properties as an individual
and not in a company mostly
is because when i started investing in
property it was 2009.
and from 2009 right up in 2016-17 i mean
they didn't even change the tax rules
officially they phased into 2020.
so nearly all of my investment life
has been when section 24 didn't exist
where it was actually
it made sense financially to buy as an
individual
so that's why i initially bought
properties as an individual
and not as a company why have i not
changed and switched it over
well it's quite simple is because taking
properties that
are owned as an individual and switching
them to a company
isn't as simple as it sounds you've got
to sell
your properties to a company and then
you've got costs like stamp duty tax on
each property so
it's quite complicated and expensive to
do it and it works out cheaper for me to
just leave my properties in my personal
name
now to answer your questions though
about yourself and about what's better
now
so it is much more tax efficient
generally speaking
now to own properties in a company than
it is to own them as an individual
that does make sense so if you're buying
a property right now
it would probably make sense but of
course speak to your accountant
to buy them in a company in terms of
interest rates
you might pay slightly more there might
be um
if especially if you're buying cheap
small houses you might pay a little bit
more
on interest payments but again it
probably makes sense still to earn them
in a company
i'd say speak to your accountant because
this is a very complex issue and every i
mean
my properties even now a lot of my
properties i'm buying
in companies i'm still buying stuff as
an individual i'm still buying stuff
that's not in my company it's outside
like this is this is all about what's
going to save you more money on tax
that's it and to get that to get that
bespoke information and guidance
i'd recommend speaking to your
accountant hope that helps guys if you
enjoy the video again do me a favor
smash the like button i'd really
appreciate that and again if you've got
a question comment it below you know
comment it below don't just sit there
listen listen to other people's
questions
put your question in and i'll answer
your question next week if i can
artist flows what is selective license i
need
for each property that i own i heard it
cost 500 pounds for five
years so selective licensing is um
this isn't in all of the country this
isn't in all of the world this is just
in certain areas
where the council say that you need a
license to own a property and rent it
out in that area
so for example the whole of wales is
is licensed so if you want to buy a
property and rent it out in wales
you need a license and there are parts
of england
where selective licensing applies like
liverpool uh i think certainly parts of
manchester
so what what it means is it means you
just need to have a license to rent a
property out and it does cost around
about 500 pounds per five years as well
so what is it that's what it is
does it cost 500 pounds five years yeah
cost about 500 pounds which which if you
think about it isn't really that much
it's a hundred pounds a year
so you just need to make sure that your
properties are cash flowing well
so it doesn't eat out of your profit too
much um i don't think selective
licensing is necessarily a bad thing
it's just it is what it is
and it's certainly going to put um bad
landlords
off if you've got to get a license it
means your property's got to be a decent
property
it means you've got to be a decent
person you can't be like a criminal or a
fraudster
so what it does is it actually makes all
the bad competition go away
which in fact actually helps helps us as
landlords because it means that there's
less
properties there's less supply of
properties because we've killed off all
the bad ones
which means that we can have a higher
rent so not necessarily a terrible thing
it is what it is i don't make the rules
i just follow them okay
kpr 400 i am buying a brr
property that is taking forever to
complete
my solicitor is asked if we wish to get
another local water and draining search
because they are nearly one year old now
should we carry out fresh searches or
not bother uh great question so
local water and draining searches the
first thing i want to say is
they don't cost that much money they
cost
about 50 pounds to get a search done
so if it's been almost a year since it
was last done
you're buying it cash you're probably
not going to need to do it again because
it's usually mortgage lenders that will
ask you um
to provide that they last they usually
expire after six months
so if it's been almost a year i'd
probably say for peace of mind
and for the sake of 50 quid which is
what it usually is go ahead and get
carry out
local water and draining searches again
so i would probably just do it again
but it's totally up to you
okay andrew raynor i'm currently working
away from home saving as hard as i can
to try and start making my money work
for me
i've managed to build about two hundred
twenty thousand pounds
sorry you wish no that was nasty twenty
thousand pounds good for you
good good for you worth of equity in my
current house but i'm crippled by
fear of failing flat on my ass and
everything not working out what's the
absolute worst
first move to make i keep changing these
words the first move i say the worst
move
um firstly andro um
you're probably right to be scared
because confidence comes from knowledge
if you haven't got the knowledge
property investing can go wrong
you can lose money you can mess up so if
you're afraid what i would say is
find somebody that's succeeding in
property and ask them to hold your hand
and walk through you the first steps
that's my advice so your first steps
should be
find somebody that's winning in property
and ask them to hold your hand and walk
with you
through your initial first few steps
because if you've got if you've got
knowledge and support and confidence
you're probably scared because you're
alone and you haven't got the knowledge
you don't want to be alone in this game
you want to be around people that are
winning
so get yourself around people that are
winning and get the knowledge
that's the best thing i would say to
start off with hope that helps smash the
like button if you're enjoying this guys
again comment your questions below
abdullah
hey samuel bro you may find my question
stupid
but i want to know what i want to know
that is rent to rent strategy well known
because i went to three real estate
agents and they said this strategy don't
work
love your content big fan thanks
abdullah i appreciate
your message is it well known um
it's not super well known but it is
i'd say probably 20 percent of estate
agents i guess would probably know what
a renter rent is
the bad news is the pusios
ruin the reputation of rent to rents for
the good people and what i mean by the
pusios a pusio
is someone that refuses to get educated
refuses to pay even a pound to get
trained
and just has a bash and has a crash okay
they're afraid to
have any skin in the game um they're the
people that take driving
less sorry start driving but without a
driving instructor you know and they're
going to end up crashing the car and
ruining the roads for everybody
it's the same the pcos they don't want
to pay a single pound for training they
don't even want to pay for books or cds
uh they get information online for free
they get a little bit of information
and then they go and then they call up
estate agents or they walk into a state
agent's offices
they mess it up they say all the wrong
things
and then the estate agent goes oh that
didn't work out well i don't like that
and then what they do is they give
everybody that does rent to rents and
proper professional management companies
a bad name
so my advice to you abdullah will be get
trained learn to say the right things
speak to agents and if the agents had a
bad idea goes oh that doesn't work
maybe ask them maybe say oh that's
interesting have you had a bad
experience or
what's happened and then just listen to
what they say
um but that's my advice but they do work
they are relatively well known but what
i'm trying to do is i'm trying to teach
people how to do rental events
properly and then make them well known
but also well accepted
in the in the professional property
community hope that helps
mike tree i have money to invest but
currently i am
time poor there is very little property
on the market where i live and i don't
have the time to travel far so i'm
considering the deal source option
what can i expect to be included in the
deal should it include recommendations
for builders agents management etc
yes mike it should if you're paying
someone to find you deals because your
time poor
i would say make sure that you they are
packaging a deal properly
i would also advise because there's a
lot of deal sources out there that are
good but there's also a lot of deal
sources out there that are bad
and if you don't know what's what and
how to do it and
what the crack is they'll pull the wool
over your eyes so i would suggest
you know really do your research do your
due diligence if you're doing if you're
paying a deal saucer
make sure they're reputable make sure
that they've got a good track record
make sure that they are compliant make
sure that they've got proper terms and
conditions
make sure that um the expectations are
made clear of exactly what you're paying
for
uh and there's also come back if the
deal doesn't come off or if the deal was
not what they said
so that's my advice good luck if i can
be of any help mike get in touch respect
all right career says is it
the best time to buy commercial retail
property
no i don't think it is commercial
property is dropping
retail shops are closing down it's
terrible
terrible time unless unless you're smart
and you're in a particular niche and you
really know what you're doing
the last thing i'd be doing right now is
buying a commercial retail property i
mean
geez um they're empty right now so and
commercial properties value based on
rent
and if people aren't wanting to lease
really really really be careful denzel
roberts can you do brr for hmo
yes you can in fact brr which is buy
refurbished refinance rent works
brilliantly for hmo because you buy a
property
you refurbish it into a hmo which means
the value is higher
the rents are higher you can refinance
pull your money out and then get nice
cash flow from it
combining strategies is a really smart
thing to do
jack wong regarding the hmo
if we buy a house and refurbish to all
four bed hmos
no hmo license is needed in an area
before the article 4 implementation
will there any impact if this area
implement article 4 next year will it be
okay to run this
hmo legally or should i apply for the
license afterwards
another question if there's no need to
apply for hmo license for those
houses less than four beds can i still
convert a house to four bed hmo
in an area under article four who's
gonna check whether or not this house is
converted
before or after the article four
implementation if there is no
requirement for applying hmo license
by the way do you have an online crash
course how can i join it
uh jack sounds like you need to join it
because i i think i understood your
question but it sounds like you're a
little bit confused about the difference
between hmo
licenses and then article 4 planning
permission they're two very separate
things
if you buy a property and it's a four
bed property and it doesn't need a
license
when article four comes in you still
won't need a license licensing and
planning and article four have nothing
in common and nothing to do with each
other
and when article four comes in you'll
have you'll have automatic planning
permission anyway
so i think you're probably worrying
about something that you don't need to
worry about at all
but you do need to be informed on the
rules of hmos because they are heavily
regulated
uh do you have an online crash course
yes i do have an online crash course uh
i'll leave a link in the description
it's 195 pounds
and it takes you through the abc of
property investing i'll give you a great
foundational knowledge
uh i'll leave details in in the in the
link great job
all right ryan lewis we'll do this as
the last question okay for this week
however if you've got questions or if
they've not been answered comment your
questions below
i'll answer those next week last
question when a limited company buys a
residential property to fix and flip
do they have to pay stamp duty when
buying if so what percentage
so ryan it really depends on the value
of the property so stamp duty there's a
sliding scale so if it's less than 40
000 pounds you pay no stamp duty
and then and then you you pay around
three percent but as it goes up and up
it goes more and more
there is stamp duty relief at the moment
uh i mean listen
if you're doing fix and flip if you're
buying a property that needs to
be refurbed if the property is not
habitable if there's no kitchen bathroom
hot water you don't pay any stamps
tuesday
so potentially you should be looking for
properties where you're not going to pay
any stamp duty at all
guys thanks so much for watching i
really enjoy answering your questions
it's amazing
please do me a massive favor though
comment below smash the like button and
please do subscribe turn the
notification bell on
so you don't miss a future video how
annoying would it be if i answer your
question
but you never even knew about it because
you didn't get a notification
when a video comes up so press subscribe
turn on the bell
and thank you so much for watching i'll
see you next time